yo what is up everybody it is prestige
amantha we need you here with another
legendary guide for Borderlands the
pre-sequel today I'm going to be showing
you guys how to get the shooting star
which is a legendary scab roid shield
its read text reads don't look up and
when the shield is depleted it grants
you melee attacks that deal bonus roid
damage and you can see on the roid
damage it gives you about plus 70 k when
it's level 46 that's even more when it's
level 49 or 50 this is a really good
shield for any melee builds especially
like melee athena is the biggest one
I've seen I've seen a few people do
melee nisha which I guess works out I
played Nisha I play Nisha and I use the
shield a little bit with her just
without any other perks and just using
it as melee and I killed a bunch of
people with a male aspect so it is a
really good shield you see I have grants
immunity to electric electric damage
that is now something native to the
shield a like all of the field as a
chance for that and I got lucky that my
shield had it so we should be showing
you guys how to get it a little gameplay
of it I do suggest any a melee build
you're definitely going to want to want
this or I think the Avalanche is another
roid dated damage shield in this game so
definitely get one of these two this is
a great sheet so enjoy and me are you
showing it showing you guys how to get
it so to get the shield you're gonna
need to head to the lunar launching
station and pick up the correct the
quest read then dead you can get this
pretty early on from getting to the
lunar launching station make sure you
wait till you finish the campaign do
this so your highest form shield now be
warned when you're going to do this
you're gonna have to either a backup
your saves or use a save editor because
this drops from an unformed bull quote
unquote boss because he only spawns once
he just a normal enemy that spawns in
while doing the mission and if he
doesn't drop it this one time that you
kill him he's not gonna spawn again and
you're not
get it so you're going to have to reopen
your saves or you're going to have to
alt f4 alt f4 and/or dashboarding
depending on if you're on a PC or a
PlayStation / xbox which is as soon as
you see him as soon as you kill them the
you're gonna have to immediately quit
out of your game without a saving now
the first cure is you're gonna be
killing couriers the first courier
doesn't matter kill him it's this second
career who's in a power suit The Lost
Legion power suit noob that's the guy
who you're gonna want now you can wait
for him to down his shields himself it
is a pretty BP shield or you can just
kill the shield yourself if you don't
want to wait so just once you get the
shields down it'll be a pretty easy kill
so shoot him up a bunch shoot up all the
other guys around him and if he doesn't
drop it this one time I'd say pretty
close to immediately alt f4 dashboard
you see I ate that much time I alt f4
and because I didn't get it because it
wanted safe now when you reload your
game you'll see you'll just get ready if
you did it right you'll have the killing
the second carrier would be the mission
and just go over do it and bingo you can
see there it dropped the grounded the
shooting star which actually I feel like
grounded the shooting star doesn't
really work as a name I feel like it
should be grounded shooting star or the
V in front of it doesn't really work
yeah so that's how you get the shield
here's a little gameplay of me playing
with it this is as soon as i got it i
just put it on and i started killing
enemies in this area so i do not have a
melee build i have no skill points in
melee damage perks yet i still kill a
bunch of guys with my melee that is a
testament to how powerful the shield is
you Angus 46 and allowed you guys are
higher levels like 47 48 so I do hope
you guys have enjoyed this video make
sure to check out my channel for more
legendary guys if you have not i am
going to be posting a lot more legendary
guys and i have posted a good amount of
legendary you guys so again hoping
enjoyed it keep look at my channel for
more to that sweet Borderlands the
pre-sequel footage and i'll leave you
with that piece up